What's it,
the,
the biggest challenge is that the,
the method that has worked so well for
economics is probably close to its
limits.
Economics has gotten a tremendous amount
of mileage about by saying what would a
rational self interested person do.
That has been the core and for very many
things that has been a very productive
way.
You learn enormous amount and,
and it serves as the basis not just for
abstract theories but for actual
empirical analysis of behavior and of
policy.
But
okay,
in a way we've sort of,
okay.
Done what you can do with that.
And more and more the key issues in
economics,
um,
are involved.
The limits of rationality involve the
places where people don't have the
ability to assess all of the data they
have where people aren't,
don't make rational choices.
There is a rapidly growing field of
behavioral economics,
which is based what that means.
I mean there's no like an hour's
behavioral,
but what that means to the economist is
that means okay,
we,
people are apparently not,
you know,
maximizing your utility function,
the way you columnists slight to assume,
which is actually a very,
very good way to understand a lot of
human behavior,
but they appear to be doing something
else.
And so all of those approaches is trying
to understand what people actually do.
That's a,
that's behavioral and a,
and we're learning a lot.
It's,
it's more of,
it doesn't have a single,
you know,
it doesn't,
can't be summarized in 10 words.
Uh,
which is why it wasn't done first.
But I think we're learning a lot,
but so it's,
that's a research program.
It's fine.
Boy influencing policy,
you know,
that's the labors of sisyphus.
You A,
you push it up a little bit,
comes back down.
Each generation has to do its bit.
I don't think there's any,
you know,
there will never be a point at which
good economic analysis is automatically
incorporated into policy.
It takes each generation to try and push
it.
And,
um,
we,
I think we're doing better.
I think this generation is,
is doing better now than it did 10 years
ago.
We'll see how,
how it,
how it goes in,
but you know,
the next generation will feel the same
frustration.